Saudi Arabia is building its first
nuclear reactor yep
the US ally just announced its plans to
build 16 nuclear power reactors the
kingdom says it's for peaceful purposes
of course construction starts at the end
of this year so who gets to decide who
gets nuclear power there's a special set
of rules you have to follow to produce
nuclear power and it's because of the
horrors of our past the world first
learned about the potential evils of
nuclear energy in 1945 when the United
States bombed Japan not that long after
Russia and Britain began to acquire
nuclear arsenals so in order to slow
down a potential global Armageddon an
international agreement the nuclear
non-proliferation treaty or NPT was
created for decades its main goal has
been to prevent countries from getting
nuclear weapons 189 countries have
signed up including countries like Iran
fantastic idea but the treaty has a few
holes in it an exclusive club including
five powers the US UK China Russia and
France have held the privileged position
of deciding who is allowed or not to
possess nuclear weapons they also have
the largest stockpiles of nuclear
weapons in the world but these nuclear
states have pledged to get rid of their
weapons
they just haven't got very far then
there's a handful of countries who
refuse to ratify the NPT India Pakistan
North Korea and Israel Israel is
estimated to have about 200 warheads and
there's more the agreement states that
the use of peaceful nuclear power is the
right of all nations wonderful but the
technology for producing nuclear energy
is just a small step away from the
technology for producing nuclear weapons
Iran claims to be exercising this
peaceful and legal rights uranium
enrichment is for nuclear power
generation not for weapons Saudi Arabia
is saying the same thing now when it
comes to the nuclear threat Iran is
always in the headlines
they haven't exactly always been
forthcoming to inspections and have been
condemned by the US and its allies but
they're a member of the NPT and
consistently say having nuclear weapons
is wrong and they have zero nuclear
weapons so Israel has nukes Iran might
soon have the capability and now the
Saudis - is this the beginning of the
nuclear arms race in the Middle East
want more download the aj+ mobile app
and join the conversation
available in your App Store now